[Music]
for sure Putin is someone who causes the
president to stay up
he's presented himself as a very unique
kind of specimen
- quite better they took a bit
vladimir Ilyich Putin the facts are
known born in st. Petersburg now aged 61
a law graduate former head of
intelligence former prime minister now a
very wealthy man
president and the latest in a long line
of authoritarian Russian leaders going
back centuries the phrase cult of
personality comes from the Russian quilt
lichnowsky Putin plays it but inside the
man Churchill's quote that Russia was a
riddle wrapped in a mystery inside an
enigma could have been written about
Putin
one thing though he's clear he
understands power and that his use of it
guarantees his place in history he sees
that's very much in line with Russia's
sense of history which is Russia as you
know third Rome was on path its third
way this is an inevitability of Russia
being such a huge country
Booton the great not yet
but 300 years after Peter the Great who
feels he has played a similar role
dragging his country into the modern
world restoring its place as a power to
be reckoned with
he knows his history and looking west
from Russia you see the direction from
which came the invaders Napoleon in 1812
the British French and Turks in the
Crimean War 1853 the Germans in 1914 and
again in 1941 the psychological scars of
this especially from World War two go
deep
sheera got himself not as politician but
as Russian Pakistan who in the very
difficult situation he filled his
responsibilities to the majority of
Russian people and also tools also often
people who lived in history Putin has
never forgiven Mikhail Gorbachev for
dismantling the Soviet Union because as
a nationalist he knew the USSR was
really the Russian Empire in ideological
clothing
Gorbachev was replaced by Boris Yeltsin
who oversaw the accelerating decline of
Russia Yeltsin wasn't always fully
focused especially on foreign policy
Eastern Europe drifted westwoods he sold
off state assets to the oligarchs NATO
announced its intentions to expand for
the Baltic States and Poland membership
equaled security Putin saw it as NATO
advancing on Russia's borders
in late 1999 he inherited the presidency
of a broken chaotic country and he said
that's enough he started at home as oil
and gas prices rose the Kremlin's
coffers swelled he began to rebuild the
military the Chechen separatists were
smashed in two brutal wars other regions
were put on notice you're not leaving
the Federation at the same time Putin
Rhee centralized power and consolidated
his grip on all sections of society
politics the courts business media in
2004 he won a landslide and was
reelected president but does he believe
in democracy
I think his experience with democracy is
that it is a sham he doesn't really have
any positive experiences of what it can
do he looks at the 1990s as an example
of what happens when democracy is
allowed to take its course he's capable
of entertaining the idea that it's
necessary to you know to achieve his
ends to at least call Russia as a state
that has democratic institutions in
order to be taken seriously
[Music]
the Americans thought they could deal
with him at a summit in Slovenia
President Bush felt he had the measure
of the men I looked the man in the eye I
finally be very straightforward and
trustworthy we had a very good dialogue
I was able to get a sense of his soul
each media video in 2008 Putin's Protege
dmitry medvedev took over as president
and he took the role of Prime Minister
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the Constitution didn't allow three
consecutive terms
so his title changed but everyone knew
he was still in charge now with Russia
stabilized the bear began to sharpen its
claws
first energy Wars Russia supplies huge
amounts of gas to European countries and
the pipelines go through Ukraine Moscow
began using gas prices to try and
influence policy but then came a real
war the Georgian conflict of 2008 put
the world on notice Russia was back on
the world stage and intent on regaining
its influence and pride especially what
it calls its near abroad for Borderlands
[Music]
its troops quickly took control of the
region of South Ossetia the Americans
growled NATO huffed and puffed but it
was clear no one except Georgia would go
to war with Russia over South Ossetia
the whole of Eastern Europe and beyond
internalized the lesson and waited for
the next move this came through
diplomacy Putin speaks fluent German
a legacy of his days as a KGB officer in
Dresden he's forged a strong
relationship with Angela Merkel Putin is
thought to believe that unlike Britain
Germany is a European power which can be
detached from overt American influence
the economic links between the two
countries are now so strong that Berlin
is constrained in how far it would go in
challenging Moscow they're very
pragmatic like he is and he values that
whereas I think the UK in the United
States at least their outward foreign
policy is more it leans more towards
ideology and and there's more talk of
human right
in late 2011 wishful thinkers said the
cracks were shown the time was almost up
in a country sick of authoritarianism
demonstrations continued for weeks into
what was dubbed the Moscow spring but
tens of thousands of Muscovites marching
in the streets did not represent Russia
mr. Putin how worried are you that the
protests will affect your election
victory are you concerned no I'm not
concerned I think about the people
ordinary people in Russia and of course
I see the protest groups and I think
about it what I can to do with all our
signals and we'd be making any further
concessions a few months later Vladimir
Putin was back as president again yeah I
did shall we get him I promised you we
would win by day Julia we won
he won at 63% of the vote down from 74
percent in 2004 but it was a margin of
victory many Western leaders can only
dream of now was some conscious elated
by the United States want a Russia
capitulation and they want to always
throw on us himself they want to crash
independent behavior of Russian
president and an behind it independent
behavior of Russia so in such situation
to fight better then took a bit late
there have been moments of pure Putin
the man who can keep the world waiting
before arriving center stage but his
personal life took a downturn he'd been
married to Ludmilla for 30 years they
have two grown-up daughters in the
summer of 2013 the Kremlin announced
they would divorce saying it was a joint
decision as they rarely saw each other
anymore there were rumors of his
friendship with a younger woman but few
details and few Russian media outlets
dared take on the story
soon there would be a much bigger story
to tell
over the border in a city Russia once
thought of as part of the motherland the
stage was being set for a dramatic act 1
which would want and for all put pay -
any doubts about what motivates Radomir
Putin and how far he will go to pursue
his aims
in Kiev the battle lines were drawn
Putin wanted President Yanukovych to
look east to join the Russian led
Eurasian Union the European Union in the
USA he wanted him in the western fold
Putin knew that would probably result in
Ukraine joining NATO the Western
alliance would then have moved right up
to Russia on a 2,000 mile long border
some people looked at the demonstrators
in Kiev and saw people fighting for
democracy Putin looked at the same
people and saw the hand of the West
attempting a coup d'etat
the demonstrators won the battle the
president fled to Russia where he was
ignored by Putin who'd always disliked
him besides he was busy the Russian
media went into overdrive saying that
fascists were behind the change in
government in Ukraine this tugged on the
psychological scars of the Second World
War there was solid backing for Putin to
make a move and the new Parliament in
Kiev made the move even easier by
downgrading the status of the Russian
language in Ukraine taking Crimea was
even easier than taking South Ossetia
six years previously
[Music]
there was popular support for the move
in the peninsula and back home and
everywhere else the same lesson was
learned as from the Georgian war no one
was coming to the rescue European Union
sanctions were a pinprick American
sanctions tougher but President Obama
was reduced to irritating Putin by
calling Russia just a regional power
what Russia is doing in Ukraine and the
designs that Russia has on Eastern
Europe have the potential to erase the
post Cold War peace dividend that has
sort of spread over Europe all over all
of Europe this is a fundamental
challenge to the established order and
it's one that needs to be met with
resolve on the part of both Washington
and European capitals it doesn't do
anybody any good to belittle Vladimir
Putin or belittle his ambitions he is
deadly serious next move Putin doesn't
seem like a gambler he may consolidate
his victory in Crimea and bill for the
next time and most analysts think there
will be the next time where I come from
geopolitics is still a competitive sport
and Putin is playing it very well he
understands that force resolve and in
particular timing of the kind that he's
exercised in Ukraine and frankly way
more and matter more than diplomacy than
negotiations no one anymore is talking
about the idea that Crimea will revert
back to Ukrainian control the question
now is Russia already has Crimea are
they going to be satisfied with it
[Music]
Vladimir Putin understands that
overreaching was part of the reason for
the downfall the Soviet Union he's
unlikely to make the same mistake and
he's got time on his side if he decides
to run again as he can he may be
President of the Russian Federation
until 2024
[Music]
you
[Music]